hey everybody welcome back to a new
episode of Jaeger horn today is a bit of
an unusual one because I'll be doing
some backstage stuff which is something
that I haven't really done in Jaeger
horn so far and normally it's something
that I do in the same episodes or at
least the times that I have done some
backstage stuff before I were doing in
the same episodes as I'm building the
facades but for Jaeger horn I did all of
the facade work and kept all of the
backstage stuff for a separate episode
which is also kind of interesting
because it means that this whole episode
I'll be building things that'll be
invisible from the park itself so really
when you think about it all the things
that I'm doing here shouldn't matter but
I think they do and I think it's
actually quite important to build these
areas for one this is a game and you're
not always looking from the perspective
of a guest and from the perspective of
me and omniscient being in this world
who is making this theme park who's
seeing these backstage areas from an
aerial perspective you know seeing that
these flimsy facades are actually just
the front of a real concrete building it
just adds to the suspense of disbelief
that this could be a real section of a
real theme park somewhere out there in
the world and I don't know I think for
me at least that's quite important and
even as a guest and looking from a guest
perspective inside the park I think
having these supposedly invisible
backstage structures is actually quite
important insofar as they're not going
to be 100 percent invisible because
you're gonna see things that hide these
things from plain sight and I think
that's the thing that sort of grounds
this park in reality if you're looking
from the perspective of a park or if
you're looking from the guests
perspective because you can see all of
these walls and the trees and the
detailing that covers up these backstage
areas so for that reason I think it
makes sense to build things that you
don't see and to build things that
you're hiding because the very fact that
there are things that you're not
supposed to see and
that are supposed to be hidden is kind
of a touch of realism in and of itself
so yeah that's my my little
philosophical deep dive into the reason
why building backstage areas for theme
parks is a good thing
generally speaking though only if you're
building parks like this that are very
heavily themed and have backstage areas
of some kind which is similar to
real-life parks like Disney parks or
Universal parks or even parks like
Fantasia lend to a limited degree but of
course not every Park of all new things
like this I think if you look for
instance at the efteling a lot of the
buildings there are a bit more real but
even then they're not entirely real and
especially for dark rides and
restaurants you'll find backstage areas
that don't look quite as fancy as the
phone as the front facades for which the
main reason is really just saving money
if there's a good reason not to build
the entire buildings the way that the
facades look is just that all of that
detailing and everything costs a lot of
money not to mention that all of these
facades use interesting roof textures
and shapes and really most backstage
areas of buildings have flat roofs which
is just cheaper and more convenient and
really these backstage areas these
backstage buildings are just sheds that
a real stage would be placed inside so
it's kind of like a commercial building
or a shopping mall in that sense that
it's really just a little outside cover
to cover a themed stage inside now there
are some important elements of these
buildings though that I do want to point
out for one there's this little roof
here that I'm decorating maybe a little
bit too much but I thought it would be
fun to at least I created which is the
side of the staff room if you have staff
in a theme park I mean I guess
technically you can't really run a theme
park without staff now can you but you
you're gonna realistically need some
rooms for
stuff to relax in and take their breaks
which is all mandated by whatever laws
in whatever part of the world you are so
might as well give them a good staff
room and an outside area where they can
sit so that's what I'm working on here
but then a lot of the banks of these
buildings would realistically also be
made up of the interiors of restaurants
of technical elements not to mention the
liveries and road access adding a large
Road in here and this road is a bit
different because this would technically
be on the inside of the park the whole
idea of Jaeger horn is to be a single
area of what it could have been in
larger Park and given that the access
road runs around the other sides of
Jaeger horn this parts this backstage
part it would actually be on the inside
of the theme park so this part is a bit
more complicated
but the other backstage areas are
connected to this access road and could
very easily get deliveries for
restaurants or whatever kind of cruise
down through these buildings into the
park so there of course besides being an
important backstage area really also
just a functional back door as well so
yeah that's really all about why I'm
building these backstage areas and why
it's kind of a touch of realism and at
least I think worth building at least to
some degree although I have to admit
that I've never gone as much into detail
with my backstage stuff as I'm doing
with this build I think the last time I
did even anything of this capacity was
probably with fantasy valley rip fantasy
valley which was all really simple and
really just concrete boxes with a few
little AC units on it and I do want to
go a bit further with this one although
I also have to point out I'm still not
an HVAC expert so I'm not entirely sure
how all of these AC units on top of
these flat roofs would work out so I'm
mostly just placing these vents and
pipes and stuff at random sort of
although I am basing some of it on some
of the Steam Workshop items that I got
so for instance those vents are actually
Steam Workshop item
and realistically there should be an
input and an output or whatever you were
technically call that it seems we're
talking about air here for the air to go
in and out and different parts of the
HVAC but when it comes to actual
placements and things like that
yeah I'm definitely not that knowledge
boss so to some degree I'm really just
putting stuff here whether it actually
works or it doesn't
I'm not entirely sure but it looks
believable enough and that's what I'm
basically going for a lot of this was
also a corner quote inspired just by
looking on Google Maps and this is
something that I often gave us a tip
whenever people ask me you know what
inspires me well for one tech talks no
but no it's something that is actually
super useful is going on Google Maps a
lot of theme parks nowadays have 3d
views and it's extremely detailed and
you can really look into the backstage
areas as well because you're looking
from an aerial perspective of course so
what I like to do is go to Disney World
which is all in 3d and it's glorious and
look behind some of the facades and look
on the roofs what it looks like what
kind of textures they have what kind of
HVAC elements are on the roofs and what
kind of backstage trucks and cars and
everything they have and that's a really
what a lot of this episode is based on
as well I'm not really copying anything
per se because the shapes and elements
of these buildings are all based on the
facades which is a bit backwards I have
to say but yeah I think overall it works
as a pretty good inspiration and
something that I like to keep open in
another tab and whenever I run out of
ideas and I'm not quite sure what I want
to do anymore just look back on it for a
second and you always find something
that's like oh I didn't think about that
I should probably do something similar
to that which yeah this whole approach
though I have to say to the backstage
buildings perhaps doesn't make the most
sense from a realistic chronological
standpoint because in real life you
would probably design the overall shape
of the building
first and then kind of plaster facades
over that which is the more realistic
approach and not following that approach
but rather building the facades first
and then just coming up with backstage
building hands are backstage buildings
afterwards did give these buildings I
think a lot more depth if you look for
instance at a lot of Disney buildings
it's really just flat walls with so much
detailing and things attached to it that
they look much more dynamic and
interesting but really when you strip
all of that detail away a lot of for
instance the Main Street USA is just
completely flat boxes the building's
barely even have any height differences
there's really just a lot of illusions
and forced perspective at play there to
make it look better than it actually is
and that's something that I didn't
really end up doing in iaeger horn I
think a lot of these buildings actually
do have a lot of depth to them a lot of
balconies a lot of different
orientations a lot of buildings of
different sizes which I think looks a
bit nicer even if it is a tiny bit less
realistic or would in any case be a bit
more expensive to build realistically so
this restaurant for instance is also you
know kind of weird in that sense the
font the front facade totally makes
sense as an alpine building I think and
really kind of has that large store or
restaurant look to it but then the
backstage buildings are just based on
what the front looks like and so it's
just a bunch of different shapes kind of
put into each other in some strange
fashion so not really the best here but
I think it's believable and at the end
of the day to me the front facades
looking good is still more important
than the backstage buildings looking
good so yeah there's my priorities for
that one anyway have moved on to a
different building I was first
adding the backstage areas to the Main
Street and this is the souvenir shop
slash restaurant that's attached to the
entrance of the coaster which is not the
best placement for a gift shop
because normally there at the end of the
the exits coming out of the station
because capitalism you want people to
walk through your gift shop after they
get off the ride and then they'll
probably be buying some stuff I don't
know normally I never actually buy
anything in a gift shop but of course
the odds are way higher if you force
people to walk through the entire store
and then there's all kinds of psychology
things at play similar to how you divide
a supermarkets but yeah that's not
something that I'm doing here so I'm
probably not going to earn too much
money on this gift shop but whatever
it's an entirely fictional gift shop
anyway but yeah this is a building where
there would be a restaurant and a gift
shop and it's completely on the other
side from the main street so I figured
it would make sense to have this area be
another place to buy merchandise or food
because it's quite a walk away to the
other place not to mention that this
also rounds up this area of the park
quite well because if it weren't for
this building there would really just be
a wall of trees around here blocking the
edge of the park which is a bit more
boring and I do like the setting that
these buildings provide and the little
Plaza that they creates between the
coaster and this building I think with
this building especially though there
will really be a sort of inside-outside
disparity because on the outside you can
see these buildings with very detailed
pitched roofs and really this building
is just a single building you know for
one it looks like multiple buildings but
in reality it's just a single blob
building but it also actually has a flat
which usually backstage areas or just
the theme park buildings in general tend
to have flat roofs because it's I think
just well yeah more efficient and cheap
as I pointed out earlier but also
probably just way more convenient to
hoist the theming and an actual
decorated area into but I guess there is
especially here kind of that weird mix
between the outside having very clearly
a pitched roof and then the inside
having
there's some kind of flat ceiling
unfortunately that's something that's
gonna have to happen I did want to build
the buildings like this though because
it's something that you typically see as
backstage buildings I do have to say
though for the Main Street I did have a
few backstage areas that kept the
pitched roofs going for a little bit
after the facades maybe that could be
some kind of entrance area for a
restaurant where you could look up to
multiple floors and look straight up to
the roof or something like that is when
I was generally imagining I don't have
an exact we've planned for these
buildings but yeah altogether it's weird
and it's something that I do want to
acknowledge because in the at the end of
the day you are very much faking things
with these kinds of buildings and you're
very much creating a stage out of the
theme park and it's not per se my
favorite thing to do but I think in this
park it's at least something realistic
to do this is also why for me at least I
really appreciate when the theme parks
are really really real and to me that
really adds something something to the
theme park so if you go to Disney
everything is obviously fake and very
commercialized but for every building
that you look at there's just you know
me being somebody who is Google 3d maps
to all of these places there's always
this that lingering thought in your mind
that's it's just facades and if you even
look from a decently aerial perspective
you'll just see weird HVAC systems and
concrete everywhere behind the facades
and just knowing that kind of destroys a
lot of the magic and the fact that there
is magic to be destroyed is kind of a
shame you know it's kind of inevitable
but there are theme parks that
definitely do it differently and that do
carry some kind of actual authentic
charm for one I visited trips trail
recently which is a park that I've
wanted to visit for such a long time and
it's also one of the inspirations for
Jaeger horn not as much it was actually
the main inspiration for Necker Park
while ago but even for this
it has some very charming kind of almost
Alpine architecture which you find very
much in the German schwaben lands as
they call it I believe but yeah
everything that you see in that Park or
at least almost everything is very much
real you'll see buildings that don't
have these backstage areas that are
completely just plastered and timber
framework and just really beautiful
traditional charming and local
architecture there's something really
cool about that and I really just like
the atmosphere that the park had and it
had buildings that you can actually walk
around because at the end of the day the
buildings in theme parks just aren't
real buildings they are just warehouses
that pretend to be buildings and on a
fundamental level you can never really
interact with them the same way that you
would in a building the inside and the
outside really never match quite as well
you can never walk completely around it
you can never go into every space that
the building has because there's just
something completely false about it and
it's really completely different from
architecture and especially theme park
scenery like this is just a whole kind
of beast on its own and I've always had
a lot of people ask me whether I'm an
architect's or something along those
lines and for one I think video game
doesn't really translate into real life
skill so I mean I don't really actually
professionally do anything related to
design or anything that I do in Planet
goes through I especially don't make
rollercoasters God in mathematics and
it's really complicated and you need all
kinds of engineering degrees for that
but even then theme park architecture is
just completely different from actual
architecture it's it's it's just all
design and barely any function which the
whole design versus function debates is
obviously raging in architecture but at
least architecture needs function to
some degree and in theme parks it's
mostly just design and then the actual
funk
it's really just some warehouse that's
hidden away somewhere and it's cool to
see theme parks that have actual
architecture that have some kind of
local charm to them and that's something
that I really love about trips tour I
highly recommend it really to anyone who
is in the area who who's planning some
kind of theme park trip and probably
hitting up europa park nearby trips to
was awesome it's really charming Park
definitely visited if you're into the
kind of South German aesthetic or if
you're into scenery focused parks in
general and it has a decent lineup of
attractions as well
carajo is a beautiful little coaster and
god I suck at these pronunciations but
goo Sanctus au is also an amazing girl
our bobsled that does some really
awesome interactions with this castle
tower that's also got a log flume in it
and that's the one building in that park
that is actually very fake because it's
obviously made out of concrete and it
has a bunch of kind of backstage looking
things to it but when it comes to the
whole entrance area and the old wooden
mill that the park is built around it's
absolutely beautiful and really cool and
for me quite a big source of inspiration
but then again I want to make this park
look like it would be unbelievably a
part of a Disney park or Universal Park
or something like that so I'm gonna put
up with these backstage elements now
when it comes to hiding stuff this is
the part where a lot of the hiding
begins and where I'm also starting to
add more detail to some of the areas so
at some points you have to transition
from the access roads to the park itself
so I'm adding some large gates that
completely block your view as well and
yeah I'm not really expanding the park
beyond this this path here would
realistically be where the rest of the
park would be where you would transition
into a different themed area but I am
as you can see we don't really have this
place for that here and I guess it took
me two years to get this far on Jaeger
horn I don't know what would happen if I
would try to build a full-fledged Park
yikes yeah I'm sorry about this guys but
hey I'm trying to finish this as quickly
as possible this episode came out in
less than two months than the last
episode which is beating my average
upload rate so I'm getting there and
speaking of getting there this park is
getting there in general it's getting
pretty close to being finished after
adding all of this backstage stuff a lot
of the sides of the park that used to be
so unfinished and used to look into the
wild open are completely done really the
only thing that I still need to look
into after this this is something where
I'm still kind of debating for myself
how far I want to go with this is the
coaster itself trying to fix some of the
issues with it and add some more scenery
here and there because I recently did
some g-force readings on the coaster and
they were pretty bad it actually hits
some crazy laterals at some point many
of the curves are criminally under
banked I based a lot of the shaping of
the coaster on Big Thunder Mountain and
the Grizzly Runaway Mine Train the only
problem is that this coaster goes
through the elements quite a bit faster
so a lot of the turns are under banks
get really high lateral g-forces and
that's something where I'm still
debating whether I want to fix it and
have to redo a lot of things or whether
I'm just gonna keep it this way and hope
that people don't care about it too much
and also you know keep things the way
under the mantra of its of a coma my
train you're gonna get lateral g-forces
put up with it because realistically
that's also kind of thing and how some
food coma my trains are extremely
over-banked
I know that Colorado Adventure
Invitational and always pushes me into
the inner corner especially on the last
helix it is really stupid how I don't
know what I mean I don't know if they
the terrible job on it or if they did it
on purpose if it wasn't purpose then
that's really cool I love it but if they
did a terrible job
it'd been God did they do a terrible job
on the banking on that coaster but I
don't really mind I really like it it's
part of the charm you know it's of a
coma you're gonna get banged up to some
degree and I like that about that a mind
train is actually kind of intense which
is also part of the reason why Jaeger
horn is quite intense this thing has a
few airtime moments even which outside
of Colorado adventure it's kind of
unheard of for vakama mine train I'm
just gonna have to look into those
lateral g-forces and then there are some
other scenery stuff that I also want to
look into finishing some of the parts
and also finishing the cue for the flat
ride and adding something alongside
that's it's something that I still need
to do whatever I'm gonna end up doing
the next episode is going to be a bit of
a mess because it's all just the
finishing touches but I hope you guys
don't mind for now I like to thank you
guys for watching and see you next time
[Music]